la función f está definida en los
números reales la siguiente tabla
muestra valores seleccionados de f esta
es la tabla que nos mencionan cuál es
una estimación razonable para el límite
de fx cuando x tiende a 1 por la
izquierda pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta vamos a
resolverlo juntos aquí lo importante es
darnos cuenta de que este signo no
quiere decir que el límite sea menos uno
a veces la mente nos juega trucos y
vemos cosas que no están ahí podemos
creer que este signo menos está junto a
este 1 de aquí pero debemos ser
cuidadosos y poner atención a lo que
leemos esto no es menos uno es el límite
de fx cuando x tiende a 1 desde la
izquierda como sabemos que se aproxima
desde la izquierda es lo que nos indica
este signo negativo de aquí nos
aproximamos a 1 desde valores que son
menores a 1 si nos aproximamos a 1 desde
la derecha es decir desde valores
mayores a 1 entonces tendríamos un signo
positivo aquí entonces queremos el
límite cuando x tiende a 1 desde la
izquierda y vemos en la tabla que hay
valores de x
aproximan a uno desde la izquierda esta
es de 0.9 que es bastante cercano a 1 y
tenemos más valores que son menores a 1
pero que se acercan a 1 cada vez más nos
interesa el valor de fx conforme x se
acerca cada vez más a uno desde la
izquierda un punto clave aquí es que
para los límites en general y no para
los límites unilaterales tenemos que ver
el valor al que tiende el límite desde
la izquierda y desde la derecha pero en
este caso solo nos preguntan el límite
desde la izquierda por lo que solamente
debemos observar estos valores es más
tampoco debemos tomar en cuenta el valor
de fx cuando x es igual a 1 pues nos
puede confundir muchas veces el límite
tiende a un valor diferente al valor de
la función justo en ese punto cuando x
es 0.9 f x es 2.5 conforme nos acercamos
a uno desde la izquierda vemos que fx es
2.1 y si nos acercamos aún más vemos que
fx es 2.02 así que una estimación
razonable para el límite de fx cuando x
tiende a 1 desde la izquierda es que
tiende a 2 no lo sabemos con seguridad
pero en el enunciado nos preguntan una
estimación razonable para el límite el
límite real podría ser 2.001 o 1.999
pero en el portal de khan academy
usualmente se dan opciones a elegir y
hay que seleccionar la que sea más
razonable y en este caso una estimación
razonable es 2 veamos otro ejemplo la
función f está definida en los números
reales la siguiente tabla muestra
valores seleccionados de f esto es
parecido al enunciado anterior pero
ahora nos preguntan por el límite cuando
x tiende a menos 2 desde la izquierda no
dejen que estos dos signos negativos los
confundan el primer signo negativo nos
dice que x tiende a menos 2 y este otro
signo indica que la aproximación será
nuevamente desde la izquierda
afortunadamente en la tabla hay valores
de x que se aproximan a menos 2 desde la
izquierda tenemos menos 2.05 y luego
menos 2.01 nos vamos acercando a menos 2
cada vez más es una aproximación desde
la izquierda porque estos valores son
menores a menos 2 cuando
y 2.05 fx es menos 20 cuando x es menos
2.01 fx es menos 100 y si nos acercamos
más vemos que fx ahora es menos 500
analizando estos datos es razonable
pensar que conforme nos acercamos a
menos dos desde la izquierda éste fx se
vuelve infinitamente negativo es decir
que no tiene límite es no acotado si
esta fuera una pregunta de opción
múltiple elegiríamos la opción que diga
que el límite de fx cuando x tiende a
menos 2 no existe y si nos preguntaran
cuál es el límite de fx cuando x tiende
a menos 2 desde la derecha entonces nos
fijaríamos en los valores de x que
tienden a menos 2 desde la derecha pero
recuerden que puede confundirnos el
hecho de fijarnos en el valor de fx
justo cuando x es igual al valor del
límite que nos interesa así que no nos
vamos a fijar en este valor solamente
vamos a analizar los valores cuando x
tiende al valor del límite que nos
interesa que en este caso es menos 2
desde la derecha si nos acercamos a
menos 2 desde valores que son mayores a
menos
vemos que fx se acerca cada vez más a
menos 4 y que coincide con el valor de
fx cuando x es menos 2 nuevamente no
podemos estar seguros del valor de este
límite con solo ver algunos datos
muestra pero aquí nos piden una
estimación razonable de este valor y en
general cuando los límites de una
función son diferentes cuando x tiende a
un valor desde la izquierda y tiende al
mismo valor desde la derecha podemos
decir que el límite de la función para
ese valor no existe como ya hemos visto
en vídeos anteriores con eso terminamos
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo